[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to thq
nordic's 2022 digital showcase i'm alex
lillywood and we are so glad you're a
part of this
so hold on to your boots
i'm richard keith and we'll be blasting
you with a tantalizing array of brand
new games and mouth-watering first looks
but that's not all we also have updates
release dates and so many other reveals
and surprises waiting for you
so let's kick things off
[Music]
[Music]
there is a house in new orleans
they call
the
rising sun
[Music]
where
thousands of young to salvation have
gone oh god she knows i'm one
don't let them get inside compare
they're not the good guy
ducero isn't cursed or blessed
it's a battleground
maybe the dark man just likes it and you
suffer
have you ever talked to a doctor about
your condition
this is madness
[Applause]
are you crazy
[Music]
welcome to the madhouse detective
[Music]
alone in the dark is a loving
re-imagination of the groundbreaking
classic survival horror game developed
by pieces interactive
it's set in the gothic american south
and players get to enjoy the experience
as either emily from the prestigious but
troubled heartwood family or edward
canby the private investigator who knows
surprising things about the paranormal
there's something evil rotting at the
core of deseto manor
to reveal its dark secret you must go
back to where it all began
desperate combat atmospheric puzzles and
a story that gazes deep inside our
protagonists haunted cells
start your ex exploration of the manor
and the horrors that lie beyond but
don't be afraid
be very afraid
[Music]
oh the phone what are these freaks
crypto
that blisk
bliss
wait a minute i thought we wiped the
blisk out
i have no explanation
but
of the planet furon
this planet is now a territory of the
furon empire
and your asses belong to me
[Music]
you gotta fill me in on this whole glisk
thing pox
they're huge hideous fruits with giant
claws and withering halitosis
imagine a cockroach mating with a
lobster boy enough already you're making
me queasy
[Music]
[Music]
and there's another problem i fear that
most of our current weapons will be
ineffective against the blisk
yeah well don't you worry your virtual
little head pocks this time they're
going down for
you want to get the disease you have to
shoot the
spores destroy them
starting with their crashed warship
bring on the boom boom
you are so cute when you do that
[Music]
you saved the princess
natalia
you should probably go over it you know
make sure she's all right
foreign
i think little krypto just woke up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
space for sale is an open-ended build-up
simulation game
you get to play a cute little astronaut
who just bought an entire solar system
and rather cheaply by the way
at least compared to london
the mission is to build new houses for
your eccentric and demanding
extraterrestrial clients
explore the worlds while scouting
locations locations locations
gather resources and study and tame the
local flora
and fauna
space for sale can be played alone or in
co-op gameplay
for the most adventurous and fun real
estate hunt in human and alien history
[Music]
get back in there
[Music]
just make sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and find some more
um
i don't see nothing
come on let's head back this is too
dangerous i go back to that pistol of a
camp no way man not until we find that
stuff
[Music]
staying true to the original while
modernizing game mechanics and control
gothic one remake invites you to
discover or rediscover the awe-inspiring
world of the mining colony on the island
korinis and to learn all the dirty
tricks you need to survive
take control of the nameless hero a
convicted prisoner whose arrival in the
colony might just change everything on a
quest to end chaos in a wild territory
now controlled by violent people and
savage creatures
and hey couldn't we all use someone like
that
well that's where you come in
[Music]
home
once it meant to my father's mention
but now
it's gone
after he was elected president
it meant his vision for our country
but when they took him
they robbed us all of that dream
i need
we
need our home back
but i can't do it alone
this is not
why would i want
this is promising
i've heard my father mention them
good day we have tracked your location
to gran xien
how may we be of service
[Music]
first step is to hire a team
then they get to work
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
father
i will save you
and i will get our home back
now i just need to get the money
jagged alliance 3 combines turn-based
tactical combat with strategic open
style gameplay for both solo or online
co-op mayhem
recruit from a large cast of mercenaries
that range from
quirky
to full-on psychotic
and use them to rescue the president of
gran chien from a paramilitary force
if you so choose to follow your contract
that is
and that mercenary roster
so many of true fan favorites to select
from
jagged alliance 3 is pulling on the
classic heartstrings for true fans
bringing the franchise back to its roots
while still adding in a few new features
for everyone to enjoy new adventures in
gran chiang
where the worst is yet to come
ever since you took that damned scepter
you haven't been yourself
you brought us here that abandoned the
fight abandoned your men and even
abandoned your vows for what
so you're alive brother
[Music]
no rest no doubt
it fools
i see you have brought friends
god's
[Music]
what happened to you
[Music]
fate is curious don't you think
after all i had to suffer and sacrifice
it puts you in my righteous path
you
don't make me do this theo
[Music]
the valiant is a tactical real-time
strategy game where you lead medieval
knights as you fight through an epic
single-player campaign
if you've been waiting for a fresh take
on rts trust me this
is your game and if online is your thing
you can also play cooperative with
friends in last man standing or test
your skills against others in 1v1 and
2v2 competitive game modes
throw in new game plus a full roster of
unique heroes each with their own skill
trees and multiple difficulty levels and
you have a replayable experience for all
types of players to sink their swords
into even you uber pros out there
that said
i ask thee
can you confront your former brother in
arms and find the missing relic pieces
before he does before he unleashes a
power that was never meant for man
raise your sword and fight
valiantly
most totally affected
[Music]
you have proven yourself loyal to me so
far general
our dynasty has waited long enough
show me
that my trust is not misplaced
[Music]
constructing
[Music]
strong though they may be
they are still flesh
[Music]
get to work
tempest rising is an intriguing
interpretation of the classic real-time
strategy games
combining base building with
hard-hitting combat
the game is set in an alternate 1997
on a planet earth ravaged after the
world's first nuclear war
you can choose from three playable
factions
each with its own distinctive play style
and features
on top of that
tempest rising features skirmish and
multiplayer game modes
with a score based matchmaking system
in short this is a must play for even
the most competitive characters and
dangerous minds out there
[Music]
welcome back sire your kingdom awaits
[Music]
the royal court is eager to hear your
orders they've garnered many new skills
to serve the realm
[Music]
our diplomats are standing by your
majesty
use them to seal powerful packs with our
allies
our merchants have established the trade
routes you requested cyan
[Music]
a neighboring monarchy is unpopular with
their people a well-placed spy could
send them into anarchy
here they see the spread to one of our
provinces
we should let our priests deal with its
sire
[Music]
[Applause]
it is time to recruit the continent's
greatest army
and protect your sovereignty by all
means
lead your men into battle
use your cavalry to flank their arches
and send soldiers to scale their wall
sire
it is the people that demand you ride
with your knights to defend what was and
the dream of what could be
[Music]
set in medieval europe as the starting
point for your legacy select a kingdom
from anywhere in europe north africa and
even parts of asia then get to ruling as
head of the royal family you make all
the crucial decisions like appointing
marshals merchants clerics diplomats and
spies to your royal court instructing
them to exert your will across the land
will you be a cunning diplomat or
a ruthless conqueror
speaking of conquest in knights of honor
2 sovereign you can take direct command
of combat yourself and lead your troops
in real time you can also head online to
play with multiple friends in epic form
with a ton of game mode options to keep
the experience fresh
this game is grand strategy with all its
allure but none of the confusion and
intimidation
[Music]
they called him renegade
freighter
an outcast on two planets
but he helped us and nobody else did
and we helped him back
[Music]
ah greetings
mark didn't expect your visit otherwise
i would have cleaned up the place
so
you come to hear the legend of the
ulukai
the ulukai could fly faster than
eventually
he could travel anywhere
from the darkest caverns of georgia to
the edge of the moon ruled by yoda
he explored ancient temples
unseen for a thousand cycles
and awaken
their powerful mysteries
[Music]
nazoka
amanore
that's more like it
use weapons were as much a part of him
as your fingers
my toes
his aim
is razor sharp
shield
unbreakable
but as mar used to tell you
fighting is half the battle
when saving a planet mar knows that a
true hero must also gain the trust of
its people
[Music]
do you want to know more
have a look
mar provides a tour for a very
reasonable price
[Music]
it's been over 20 years since appeals
studios genre redefining and
award-winning open-world action
adventure took the world by storm
but now
cutter slade your favorite neighborhood
invader slayer is back
taking control of our hero you return to
the alien world of adelpha after being
resurrected by the almighty yods
your mission is to save the planet by
joining forces with the oppressed talons
and fighting against the invading forces
as well as the dangerous wildlife
as you explore the unique and lush
environments your freedom of movement is
simply breathtaking
there's even a jet pack at your disposal
childhood dream come true
bets are on that outcast 2 will take the
world by storm
as if once wasn't enough
breaking news here in sledgehammer
county after a sharp increase of car
racing activity in recent days
authorities now report a staggering
amount of items and race tracks popping
up out of nowhere
jan
what do you make of it
well bill it's like you say random bits
and pieces of race tracks along with all
different kinds of items have been
emerging all over the county and wait
i'm just getting word that these pieces
now seem to be rising into the air
forming an ever expanding aerial
racetrack and eclipsing the sky above
sledgehammer
bill
i've never seen anything like this
you have to wonder who is behind this
and
where does it end shadows
[Music]
targets in their side
running out of life
to save
[Music]
you say
[Music]
recreation is an open world arcade
racing game
and when we say open world we are as
serious as a highway speeding ticket in
switzerland
there's 450
000 kilometers or 280 000 miles of roads
for races to go completely
and legally mad across a customizable
400 000 square meter world that's just
over 150 000 square miles you can also
choose from an arsenal of over 30
vehicles across multiple categories and
with the live mix feature build your
tracks on the fly and share them with
friends
happy
semi-safe travels
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
only four days to go as hunting season
starts on august 16th
in way of the hunter you step in to take
over your grandfather's small high-end
meat business in the pacific northwest
upon arriving though you find out a
rival has taken over the entire region
with illegal and unethical methods of
hunting
become the new owner of a hunting lodge
nestled among gorgeous habitats in this
open world game
animal and animal herd movements are
incredibly sophisticated
and together with hyper realistic
firearms handling and bullet physics it
virtually guarantees an unforgettable
adventurous escape to nature
whether playing alone or with a friend
in multiplayer co-op
by the way just in case you still miss
your car
there's an off-road vehicle for you to
roam around with which acts as your
mobile hq
but much more important than your
sensible driving style
is your ethical hunting strategy
[Music]
tony hey what are you doing hey what are
you doing what are you doing going to my
room no what going welcome get your back
come on come on come on
don't step on the pizza don't let
anybody stand up come on
oh no get in first
leave your
what's happening here
aew fight forever video game happened
here
all right so
now what
um well are you hungry
um my second thought donate that now
it's finally time to reveal aew fight
forever to our aw fans at the thq nordic
digital showcase
check it out tony i will be me the word
legendary dmd and you be adam cole
oh man this this game is awesome i told
you you would love it i told you am i
ever wrong no
i should have never
oh
this game is it's tremendous are there
any weapons in this game
are there any weapons
[Applause]
cool
look how easy this is to play you didn't
have to figure out a million freaking
buttons even though i could have because
i'm a dentist
but i just picked it up today and
started playing and i'm already the best
at it and
career mode wow mini games i'm really
excited you tell me about career mode i
can tell you that and almost lost my
mind when i found out that aw fight
forever has mini games how did you find
out about the mini games you told me aew
fight forever coming soon
d
and d knock your teeth out shivani
[Music]
well
at least i'm a good dentist
today players have been offered a mere
glimpse of what aw fight forever has in
store
this game delivers the unbridled energy
and the high-flying over-the-top
personalities synonymous with the
elite wrestling league
plus i should probably let you know that
aw fight forever will be playable for
the first time ever
inside thq nordics booth at gamescom in
a couple of weeks so drop by and feel
first hand what it's like to lay down a
finisher and feel the pot of the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
just break out
until everybody break out
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
stunt fest world tour hits bang on the
sweet spot where racing and extreme
sports mix and merge and melt
18 players have to race wreck and bounce
to compete against each other in an
elimination based stunt show
with various outrageous game modes
take advantage of quirky gadgets
including the unique ejection mechanism
to blow the competition away
do you have what it takes to be the best
and the best
then we've got big news for you
right after the stream
we have a vip hours special with only
500 exclusive seats via the stream play
test feature
you will be one of the first to try out
the game and get the chance to compete
against content creators online
later today we'll increase that number
and tomorrow stunt fest world tour is
ready for all of you all day so
let's write stunt history together
[Music]
i told you look at all those snails the
monster kidnapped look it's gary
[Music]
so how do we save gary without that
monster snail seeing us there he is the
monster snail huh
they grew up so fast don't they these
massive amounts of candy bars must have
given him a sugar rush we can't take him
back home like this we have to cut off
his candy supply first already on it
buddy
[Music]
squad
[Music]
squidward
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i say we once took things off
[Music]
citizen in need karate bob to the rescue
[Music]
those jelly extras were very
convincingly beating me up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tray
[Music]
[Music]
everything is possible in the infinite
expanses of the cosmos there might even
be a reality where mayonnaise isn't an
instrument
when the mysterious fortune teller
cassandra grants spongebob and patrick
wishes the two buddies unintentionally
open up portals to strange wish worlds
it's all fun and games until their
friends get lost in the portals
explore seven distinct worlds and don
more than 30 cosmic skins to rescue the
universe of the brand new adventure
spongebob squarepants the cosmic shake
meet all your favorite bikini bottomites
from the series voiced by their original
actors
everybody do
the cosmic shape
wow
wow we made it i mean we announced so
many games it was there i have lost
count but let me tell you this they are
in my calendar and i hope that they're
in yours too yep i can't wait to get
probing
well make sure you renewed your license
and thank you so much for being a part
of our digital showcase today we'll see
you again soon
goodbye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh it's coming
you